من الحرب في اوكرانيا الى الحرائق في
اسبانيا والبرتغال وصولا الى ازمه تايوان
واخيرا كاس العالم في قطر تميزت العربيه
بتغطيات جابت فيها العالم لتنقل لكم الخبر
من مكان حدوثه في التقرير الاتي نستعرض
واياكم جانبا من تغطيات زميلنا لايت
بازاري قبل ان نتابع معه
نحن هنا في درب السيل كما تشاهدون في عنق
السوره الحافله التي تحمل لاعبي المنتخب
الارجنتيني هاي الاجواء هنا وهناك شكرا
[موسيقى]
من مناطق الغابه والبلدات المنكوبه
والمحظوره ليث بزارين العربيه اسبانيا
من الحدود الاوكرانيه الرومانيه هذا مفتاح
منزلها في كياف وهذا مفتاح بيت والدتها
هذا الطريق الحدوديه الجبليه الصغير الذي
يفصل الاراضي الاوكرانيه منها رومانيا
[موسيقى]
انا الان علمتني هذه الباخره العملاقه
التي ستعبر بحر البلطيق متجهه من هنا من
السويد الى فنلندا
[موسيقى]
يحمل الكثير من الفنلنديين تاشيرات عبور
روسيه ما يمنحهم فرصه دخول الاراضي
الروسيه نحن هنا في صفوف غابات تبرع
التابعه لاقليم تمر الاسباني نحن هنا جنوب
جزيره تايوان في منطقه
[موسيقى]
ومعنى هنا في الاستوديو والزميل لايف
بازيري ليطلعنا على الكثير من التفاصيل
اول شيكل عام وانت بخير عيد ميلادك اليوم
هاي هديتنا لك صور رائعه
طاهر الانساني العاطف عندما شاهدت هذه
السيده على الحدود الاوكرانيه الرومانيه
وهي تحمل مفتاح بيتها بالقضيه الفلسطينيه
تحديدا عندما غادر الفلسطينيون اراد 48
وكانوا يحملون المفتاح بيوتهم العوده يوما
ولكن هذه السيده قالت لي سنعود نحن هنا في
بولندا او في رومانيا تحديدا لبدعه ايام
وسنعود الى بيتنا قريبا ولكن عليه ان اترك
البلد من خارج كيف تحديدا لاكون هنا وهذا
مؤثر جدا علينا خاصه
باسبانيا والبرتغال موضوع الحرائق ايضا
لانه عم نرجع نشوف الصور لاهم هذه
التغطيات شو اللي ابرز ما تذكره من هذه
التغطيات حجم الخطوره التي كانت عليكم
النقطه الاقرب التي استطعتم الوصول اليها
نعم هذه العواصف الرمليه الرماديه الى صح
التعبير ولكن الاهم من ذلك طاهر اليوم
الذي يحدث في اسبانيا نعرف جميع ما يحدث
في اسبانيا من تصحر ولذلك ان نعيد مشاهده
تلك الاشجار التي لم تحترق او لم يحترق
البعض منها سوف يحتاج الامر الى 12 عاما
وهذا ليس اكيد ان ترجع ان تنمو هذه
الاشجار مره اخرى مع التغير المناخي هذا
هناك الكارثه اكثر من شاهدنا طبعا في هذه
القريه التي تقع في ثمره وكان طبعا قوات
الدفاع المدني يقومون باخلاء بعض المسنين
الذين رفضوا تركب بيوتهم للحفاظ على
منازلهم ممتلكاتهم ولا ولا يخشون اثنت
النهار طيب بدنا ننتقل الان الى فنلندا
همم يعني ليست منطقه حرب المعنى الكامل
الكلمه ولكن على مشارف منطقه حرب ونحن
نشاهد الصور الخاصه بفنندا في تغطياتك
حدثنا عن جزئيه القرار كيف تتخذ قرارا همم
الى اي حد ستدخل في منطقه معينه الى اي
حدث الى اي حدث ستخاطر بنفسك بالفريق الذي
معك كيف يتم التعاون مع همم اداره همم
العربيه في ما يتعلق بهذا الموضوع مع هيئه
البرامج او التحرير نعم عاده عند عندما
نذهب الى منطقه محظوره بين قوسين نحاول
دائما الاقتراب بحذر وعلينا دائما ان
نحافظ كما تفضل قبل قليل همم على خصوصيه
المنطقه العسكريه اذا اذا صحت تعبير ولكن
كانت الصدفه او شاءت الصدفه ان نذهب الى
منطقه الحدود الروسيه الف عندما ركبت على
متن باخره من ستوكهولم الى هيلسنكي وعاده
هذه هذا الخط ال- ال- البحري يحمل خصوصا
صيفا عندما صورنا هذا التقرير او هذه
التغطيه يحمل عاده روس يتوجهون الى اوروبا
لقضاء الاجازه الصيفيه ولكن مع اغلاق
الحدود شاهدنا الكثير منهم يتجهون عكسا من
روسيا الى فنلندا ومن ثم من حيث سنك الى
ستوكرم
للخروج من روسيا والهرب كما نشاه الحدود
نشاهد روسيون او روس يتركون على المنطقه
المتجهين الى اوروبا الغربيه
الان وهي كانت ايضا محطه انذار العالم في
20 22 خاصه
لجهه الخشيه العالميه من اقدام الصين في
تايوان على ما اقدمت عليه روسيا في
اوكرانيا نعم صحيح وهذه الصور تشهد على
ذلك كيف كانت التدريبات التايوانيه طاهر
في هذه المنطقه والادها من ذلك عندما
وصلنا الى مصانع السيليكون دكتورز او
اشباه الموصلات لم اتوقع يوما من الايام
ان تقوم حرب في العالم وهذا صحيح حول
شرائح الكترونيه وهذا ما يحصل تحديدا في
تايوان والكثير من التايوانيون يريدون
يعني مش الكثير البعض منهم يقدم ولائه
للصين ويامل ان تكون تلك المصانع او
المصانع اشباه الموصلات في الصين وهناك
طبعا شاهدنا الانتخابات التي حدثت في
الخامس والعشرين من نوفمبر في تايوان
والكثير صوته للصين
اكثر كاس العالم
بعد قليل نراها الان اعتقد تخبل همم
للوطن العربي وللشعب العربي المواطن
العربي العربي
فازت المغرب على احد المنتخبات في كاس
العالم وطبعا لا انسى الشاب الاردني عندما
قال لي بلاد العرب اوطاني من الشامي
لبغداد ومن نجد الى يمن الى مصر فتطوانه
هذه كانت 360 اذكر تماما واخر المداخله
عند كنت اسلم منها ولا راويه وقام طبعا
بالاقتراب من الميكروفون وقام
بقول ما هذا النشيد العربي الشهير ليث همم
يعني انت كنت بتعمل كثير تقارير سياحه في
العالم
انتقلت بعدها الى الكثير من المناطق
الخطيره والمناطق اللي فيها تحديات واللي
فيها حروب ما بعرف يعني حسدوك الناس على
ما كنت تكون مع انه انت كتبت لي انه صعب
جدا يعني حتى لو كان في اطار السياحه
والاكل وغيره عن ظهر فينا نقول مش 360
درجه 180 درجه تغيرت حياتي
لا يوجد هناك
ذلك طبعا توجهنا الى هذه المغامره التي
بدات مع كورونا في يوكوهاما دانو برنسس او
باخره الباخره المبوءه انا اذكر تماما في
شباط عام 2020
واصعب تغطيه او الاكثرها يعني همم
باعتقد التجربه الحدود الاوكرانيه كانت
حدود اوك نعم ابدا ولكن انجحها هي التي
تجربه
ان يكون هناك في بلد عربي انجاز عربي
ومنتخبات عربيه تصل الى مراتب لا تصل لها
من قبل شو يعني لك انك تكون بالستوديو بعد
كل هاللف والدوران في العالم
هدوء
كويس شكرا يعني ما بعرف اذا عم تهجينا ولا
عم تمدحنا ولكن اشكرك جزيلا ههه
يعني مو فاضي العربيه المتنقل المتجول في
العالم شو المخططات 20 23 ان شاء الله لحد
هلا عيد ميلادنا اليوم راح نشوف الايام
المقبله اكيد بترتاح يعطيك الف عافيه شكرا
هنا في درب اللستيل كما تشاهدون في عمق
الصوره الحافله التي تحمل لاعبي المنتخب
الارجنتيني هاي الاجواء هنا وهناك شكرا لك
يا نسرين
[موسيقى]
من مناطق الغابات والبلدات المنكوبه
والمحظوره ليتزاري العربيه اسبانيا
من الحدود
اذا احصيت سبع وخمسون وفاه
[موسيقى]
نعود اليكم بعد هذا الفاصل القصير فارجو
ان تتفضلوا بالمقائن معنا
[موسيقى]